stéphane walker botta breite minister
jetzt haben wir beispielsweise diese
kopfhörer für 54 eur 25
hey leute was geht ab von hertz
willkommen zu einem neuen video ja leute
ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut ich habe
heute meinen bruder dabei der hilft wenn
ich heute wir machen einen neuen part
von viralen tik tok live hacks ich habe
fünf rausgesucht davon wirst du zwei
testen die man nicht kennt
das ist nämlich ganz wichtig heute und
ich drei weitere die ja auch nicht kennt
wobei die du machen musst die sag ich
dir vor wollen das wäre sonst dumm weil
dann haben wir nämlich noch deine
reaktion auf diese genialen sachen die
wir gleich machen wir das erste was wir
jetzt machen werden kann ich schon mal
sagen es verfahren zu einer doppelt weil
das ist der einzige weg den ich immer
mal gesehen habe den ich irgendwann mal
gesehen habt aber den ich mal gefunden
hab ich weiß wie er funktioniert aber
ich habe kein video dazu wenn du
irgendwas bestellt und dann im auto es
muss darum geht es nämlich das ist so
revolutionieren für mich dass es sie
einfach genial leute letzte okay leute
da sind muss ich mir jetzt ganz schön
schnell
wir brauchen auch gar nicht viel und man
das ist immer so tötung das ist immer so
blöd
dadurch dass das jetzt alles so voll ist
müssen wir jetzt so lange anstehen weil
man kann ja nicht reingehen naja dann
warten wir noch ein bisschen
ich hätte gerne der mittlere pommes und
ketchup und mayo dazu das war schon ganz
schön teuer irgendwie herr lienz pass
mal auf
wir haben jetzt hier ketchup mayo und
komik ja ich hatte das auch schon
richtig oft so dass ich im auto halt
essen wollte was macht man dann
man nimmt sich diesen catcher und macht
dann irgendwie hier vorne habe ich denn
immerhin gemacht hier so auf dieses auf
diese ablage auf seine servierten du ja
wahrscheinlich auch oder die man ohne
kitsch oder minuten dann könnte man so
gar nicht erst aufgemacht was aber auch
jetzt zeige ich dir noch nicht richtig
was richtig genial ist das eigentlich
total einfach ist aber ich hab selber
nie draufgekommen den ketchup auf sagt
diese ablage damit tut man was für eine
ablage bei deinen bei deiner kommen da
bei der papier vorführeffekt jetzt ist
das nicht richtig auf mit dann probieren
was nochmal hiermit nochmals die mayo
auch so und jetzt machen wir einfach
folgende das eigentlich das simpelste
der welt wie bei sich
also man kann einfach die pommes hier
ein kippen oder ich sagte du meintest
das ist doch viel besser aber das ist
doch total um so kann absolut nichts
passieren weil ich schon so oft auf der
couch hat dann irgendwie herunterläuft
oder so simpel aber genial okay wir
fangen spielen nach hause weil ja kommen
wir zu sachen die kann ich noch nicht so
ganz glauben und ich bin doch wirklich
sehr sehr skeptisch gegenüber
eingestellt ob das funktionieren kann
wir machen heute ganz viel von so einem
typen hab ich gesehen daher sagt iphone
gibt es umsonst amazon sachen umsonst
schauen uns alles an amazon können sogar
glaube ich vielleicht wirklich glauben
beim iphone mini noch sehr skeptisch
sollte herzlich willkommen zurück nach
sofort und schwamm drüber wir sind jetzt
wieder bei uns zu hause und jetzt machen
wir weiter
du bist obwohl warte mal kurz überlegt
man gerade ich mache noch ein und dann
bist du dran okay aber wir gucken uns
denn jetzt zusammenhang jetzt willst du
mich interessant ich weiß gar nicht ob
ich das im titel schreibe auf jeden fall
habe ich was gefunden der typ meint oder
will uns zeigen wie man umsonst von
amazon produkte bekommt es klappt also
ich kann mich ein bisschen aus in diesem
bereich deswegen es können schon klappen
ich zeig euch macht das ganze natürlich
schon ein bisschen vorbereitet und
bereits drei stopps an geschrieben ich
mach das jetzt einfach mal ganz kurz
noch mal nach wir geben hier meinetwegen
kopfhörer ein sowie der typ im video
weil ganz wichtig da muss ich euch auch
gleich was
sagen und dann suchen wir jetzt
irgendwie kopfhörer aus die erst 20
rezensionen haben wie zb diese hier das
macht schon sinn also dass die so wenig
haben jetzt haben wir hier
beispielsweise diese kopfhörer für 54
eur 52 sodann kann ich jetzt natürlich
den shop schreiben und fragen ob ich
davon umsonst haben kann
für eine gute rezension blende ich euch
immer ein ich habe das bei drei
verschiedenen shops gemacht und dann
zeige ich euch natürlich gleich auf die
antworten und mainz gesagt geklappt nein
ganz kurz zur erklärung die meisten
amazon händler das sind eher einfach
leute wie du und ich man kann sich daher
anmelden
wie bestellt zum beispiel produkte aus
china kaufen 10.000 trinkflaschen für cs
trinkflasche verkaufen in deutschland
für zehn euro pro trinkflaschen das
heißt wenn diese trinke zehn euro kostet
und nicht die frage ob könnt ihr mir die
umsonst geben ich schreibe eine gute
rezension dafür werden wahrscheinlich
viele jahr sagen weil ich einfach nur
zehn cent für eine trinkflasche
ausgegeben haben und eine rezension ist
dann halt einfach viel mehr wert weil
dann viele leute geräts millionen ist
natürlich dann gut oder diskussionen
kaufen wenn das produkt im einkauf jetzt
allerdings 100 euro für den händler
kostet dann wird das mir wahrscheinlich
nicht geben weil er mal 100 euro verlust
für eine rezension das ist ja nicht im
gleichgewicht dadurch dass ich jetzt
zwei kopfhörer vier mann eine maus
angefragt habe so eine computermaus habe
ich sogar eine antwort bekommen wo das
wirklich jemand machen würde dann würde
mir umsonst diesem ausgeben
verstehst du das macht ja schon sind
deswegen man kann das versuchen und es
gibt bestimmt einige die das machen
allerdings ist es ein bisschen
fragwürdig weil das funktioniert
natürlich nicht für alle produkt aber
versucht den euer glück ich bin euch
hier super gern mal die antwort ein ja
hätte ich jetzt computermaus hier
wahrscheinlich für 50 cent eingekauft
hat so jetzt ist merlin dran und zwar
ich habe ziemlich verraten ich habe
gesagt das geht um spotify und erkannte
dass einfach ich habe das noch nie
irgendwo gesehen und dieses tik tok
video ist eigentlich auch nicht so
bekannt deswegen wir bleiben es euch
hier mal ein
ich hätte gar nicht gedacht dass es um
bei dem klappt alles funktioniert auch
bei meinem pc
[Musik]
also wir können und diese spotify
leuchte leiste zum leuchten bringt zu
einem laserschwert mal gemeint so aber
ist er leuchten dann und das gab es auch
schon mit anderen geben praktisch andere
variationen
außerdem gibt es und was war denn da
irgendwie so neben okay leute weil ich
habe euch hier einen imac das ist ja ein
anderes betriebssystem warte stop shops
ach das war es jetzt schon leuchtet was
muss man da eingeben
aber das thema sex muss groß sein
ich blende euch immer den code eingeben
müsst wieder im video und zeigt mir
jetzt spielst musst mal ab
[Musik]
das lasse ich so das ist aber jetzt wenn
die polizei schließt wieder öffnet ist
es weg ach so ja ich muss erstmal
eingeben gut ich fand den eigentlich
sogar genial listen also ihr könnt gerne
mal kommentieren welchen ihr bis jetzt
am besten sollten wir haben natürlich
noch einige wieder von dem typen mit
diesem amazon von gerade der eigentlich
auf seinem twitter-account das meiste
ist meiner meinung nach absolut fake
also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
das geht ist eigentlich sonst käme
account der trotzdem irgendwie
funktioniert ja wir schauen uns jetzt
noch was von dem an und zwar hat er mir
gezeigt wie man ganz einfach jeden film
kostenlos schauen kann indem wir einfach
bei google eintippt
das macht jetzt auch wieder deuce ok to
watching you free state drive der
folterkammer potter band jeffrey google
voice of the one ist auch mit dunkel
wenn im anderen filmen wir nehmen batman
michael weil er meint er geht mit 1 film
also ich kann mir eigentlich nicht
vorstellen dass das geht weil google ist
ja also wenn man kostenlos filme schauen
möchte wir schon auf ich weiß nicht ob
ich das hier sagen dazu gibt ja so
seiten a4 und erkennt er verstanden aber
das ist ja über google drive eigentlich
was total seriös legal deswegen werden
das geht das wird mich schon echtes
wunder
schauen wir mal wir gehen mit solchen
film ein google muss sich dann das ende
und jetzt gibt mir ein irgendwie batman
einfach dann keine ahnung the dark
knight ok unter alter immer drauf können
wir das jetzt machen und da ist das hab
ich dann wieder klickt man darauf egal
noch mal sie können auf diesen inhalt
nicht zu greifen ja habe ich mir schon
gedacht also absolut weg bevor wir jetzt
direkt sagen fällt ich versuche einfach
mal joker irgendwie bei dem stand ja
auch mp3 mp3 audiodateien mp4 also keine
ahnung gibt man einfach nur ein
mitwirken
er hat ja auch aus amerika darauf
zugegriffen aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass so funktioniert weil in
amerika ist google hat auch google ich
habe jetzt jedenfalls gefunden wenn ich
mir das jetzt runterladen ich glaube ich
bewege mich hier auf illegalen raum
kannst du da richtete wollen wir
versuchen es ist halt illegal und es ist
ein kurzes fazit also ich würde gar
nicht mal sagen dass es auf keinen fall
funktioniert es könnte schon
funktionieren aber es ist halt genauso
illegal wie diese ganzen anderen
streaming dienste also ist der raubkopie
ich weiß dass nicht wieder die in
amerika ist das wahrscheinlich noch
strikter geregelt deswegen macht es
besser nicht erst können funktionieren
aber es ist illegal und somit meiner
meinung nach ist ja nicht weg aber es
ist halt grenzwertig machen wir weiter
habe ich glaube ich noch das kleine
gemacht
mainz es geht warum ich müsste ja dann
mit diesem code diese weise nicht
tausend euro hat ein komplett verfallen
und so als bester 1000 euro gutschein
ja ich hab's aber schon verstanden
willst du mal ausprobieren du bist dann
hast du ja klar
also das war dieser account den ich da
gefunden habt wo eigentlich nur so eine
scheiße ist aber also entweder der macht
irgendwas illegales der macht irgendwas
was halbwegs funktioniert oder irgendwas
was sie überhaupt nicht funktioniert und
so viele menschen schauen sie sich das
an also so ganz weil ich das nicht wir
machen auf jeden fall noch weiter jetzt
hat wieder spaß gemacht ich suche weiter
raus lassen nach oben da medien es auf
instagram berlin.de genau und mir könnt
ihr auch gerne folgen abonniert auf
meinen neuen kanal alex v da gibt es
jeden tag sich am wiesengrund oder soja
jahr 14 auf alex frau und ich aber noch
jetzt vielleicht ein gaming kanal der
heißt alex und danke fürs zuschauen
haut rein bis übermorgen hallo leute
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen live
act von mir heute zeige ich euch wie ihr
die spotify läsionen zum leuchten bringt
ganz einfach ihr geht hier oben
aufsuchen und gibt ein thx 1138 ganz
wichtig tax groß dann drückt er älter
und hier unten leuchtet dafür ein like